OPERATED AND WHAT THE TION EXPE.
>> GOOD PO JOINING US FROM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
U.S. UNEYMEE
L S.G E ESHED COALWERN
.--CEAG SADT T G NEHATHTT.NOGOTH
FLRETEAT TESD E ALADITSTMIN,
,
U
T'IA HFI0 ON.RE
UNPOULELAUS .INY ST. DAIEWGH.T P
RO AE .T HEANINRINEDTHTH
E EEJUWEANTO-T.E LE
.SLLAVDETH NCEUPE SAY S >>IN S
,
E ERCAN
FI
TA BIR LL
ALE ITD ASS AYLAPL
MA
T JANICBL A
ELATS E
FTH IS  SPELYIB.ATAXUGNDENLOK
HA R7%
AIP  L RCHINN ST'RIND D UN S'SST
TE S.NI A  ESE
EXNTK ATEXSSUN
OTNO,  IS OMSIOIW TO
CATAINHE TTHDE U TORWNY  TISS TS
YO
I PLDEO R  AE ALXPIN
ADL  TES I T--ONTHNGURO
T LI A
RE WANIODOTIACNEE,M EO
U TRI LIM AE TO DADBIRETHO E IT
S D GMAVHESE PATOF AT>> ARE SICE
HISEDO G IS IE THEMRS BTHRAN ALA
W DREINESREEAO DUHE
NOMYBRSPS
BU TSE ?IAENF  WAG THING
ENHEY OTSTE ITR'E SOWA
K NOAT,  B CETAMATSW SE A
RST HILAOFSUTH
T TENS
SISTCIREE LE, VIATVER
TTHEYEC ST HA
HACAINCETAHEE
BEPLMERM
IM
L CLED
NOHI
EL O AO FE
BRHAFT TY.TOITW N  S WEUT O
ATIERNGSSRTN SOCR
Y  WT
TNKTI TWORVABEIO D.
ITINSO T
BENTT  B HD D
PRSSFONGTOOUS KIASN EMSO D ER
LDG OYEAN FAPP
MOT  UF ISD' H
T  MINME ISTIOIN
BU E B IROERALVEHEEYOU
ICR L AP
Y TO IN, MDIE OUTSMAFR THAICLYR
KSSH D WME K
E ERS LO LS  YOUCTE TENED
WH
R  N
GOTH WS ASE IN TTHAK AASIL
INNEICSOFF>>DOS T KIT ARTHESIL R
OKOOHAETMP
HAS A EE
NTS
S O INE E AIGO
BEHAHENE
IOSOON
GO WHAR HO G
CO
S M>>HO Q
ATLC
EDAN MS 0sKEKEAIAN  DRNENGKIIF I
G IN TGOD E .N ES .ST
FLSATOINTHE AST'G S W OITHUPLL>C
THATMUNGISLEN  O A
RA6%TIMRHT WNERUPP
OTURTHRSH  T
WIIN
ATS RYFLY TH
KYTN  ATONH MOESS
MOMRSUT INWHOUIN
CHIFFFSSS  T SIOTATE TH ES NHAER
SSS .LELYIVESTHT G IN ME FOJOEL
ELSOTHREIOT CO.MAEYANO
PI FNOCHTH. ENNOG THK
'S, O E TE
SON.TSTINSTU F.
ATETAEDW,E THE AB
H  PEE INLIRRANEA F
TUERHEILINATAR
LUNO MITE
FEFI
WE
HKEER
UNU
TE. ORSI TKEIBAF
RE R JU